début de semaine enfant phare dans
l'atelier de la boulangerie de
Château-Renault toute l'équipe vit au
rythme de la meilleure galette de France
une galette à la frangipane qui va être
la star de ce mois de janvier pas de
secret dans les ingrédients de la reine
des galettes une farine locale des œufs
du beurre des amandes du sucre le vrai
secret est à faire de goût et de
proportions
c'est le travail de la frangipane avec
la gamme d'amande vous avez à quelque
chose qui va amener il y a crème
pâtissière et la crème d'amande vous
voulez travailler ensemble ça va amener
une légèreté et après c'est la quantité
que vous mettez dedans qui va amener
beaucoup plus de souplesse et beaucoup
de
parfums en elle-même cela fait 5 ans que
le chef pâtissier peaufine sa recette de
concours en concours avec le soutien de
toute son équipe en décrochant le prix
national de la meilleure galette des
rois Hervé baudet assure la renommée de
l'établissement et un report des ventes
prévisibles pour l'épiphanie
nous en a demandé de un peu partout en
France on nous a demandé même pour
partir sur sur les Caraïbes et autres
donc bon après on faut rester
raisonnable on peut pas aller fournir
tout le monde donc il fallait qu'on en
envoie à Rungis pour que ça prenne
l'avion donc non là ça reste dans la
boutique c'est à Château-Renault de 3000
galettes vendu l'an dernier la
boulangerie prévoit d'en vendre le
double cette année même si ça reste une
spécialité de Château-Renault on vient
toujours chercher quand même la galette
ici mais particulièrement cette année
ils ont gagné c'est la meilleure de
France on veut vraiment la goûter
la République ne tire pas les rois dans
son palais pourtant Hervé baudet sera
reçu à l'Élysée ce jeudi sans fève ni
couronne suprême consécration pour sa
galette championne de France